a los siete años mi padre me llevó a un
concierto de música clásica por primera
vez y salí llorando tocaban la quinta
sinfonía de beethoven
como preparas un niño antes de que vaya
a un concierto de música clásica por
primera vez bueno unos días antes nos
sentamos a escuchar una grabación que él
tenía y ahí me explico un par de cosas
sencillas como por ejemplo la
insistencia del está patatán
a lo largo de todo el primer movimiento
pero que además regresa más tarde en la
sinfonía que esta sinfonía tenía cuatro
movimientos o cuatro partes o que el
final de ésta sería una victoria una
victoria humana musical concreta o
abstracta que lo que comienza con un
insistente y sentencioso llamado se
convierte en un triunfo lleno de
validación y optimismo incluso jugábamos
a un juego cada vez que comenzar una
sección de la que habíamos hablado y
apretar y a su mano en señal de
reconocimiento con esta información
llegue al teatro esto y la natural
curiosidad me cargaron de expectativas
por una parte estaba tan concentrado si
disfrutando de la música pero también de
la experiencia extra y el público atento
a la orquesta numerosa el sonido
apasionado
todo iba según lo había anticipado hasta
que de pronto ocurre algo increíble algo
que hasta el día de hoy sigo
considerando uno de los momentos
musicales más perfectos jamás escritos
un milagro
la música hace un rato venía repitiendo
un gesto lo identifican pero además una
sucesión de acordes que me hacían pensar
que después de esto seguramente vendría
esto
una suerte de sentido común musical pero
no hay nada de milagroso en eso o sea
humildemente esa resolución también la
podría haber escrito yo y de paso
terminamos el movimiento y dejamos que
la gente está tranquila y
compulsivamente nos han dado cuenta o
que revisen su teléfono
pero esta música no la escribí yo y
petos en espeto feng por algo
retrocedamos unos segundos de esa música
todo esto sigue un patrón y ya sabemos
cómo debería concluir
y esto no me lo esperaba un niño diría
como que te engaña
esa nota salida de otro universo sonoro
sorprende la música el ritmo late apenas
al filo de su extinción pero poco a poco
se estabiliza como dando señales vitales
de ese impulso brotaron los violines y
una línea melódica errática e
intermitente insegura incluso hasta que
también encuentra consistencia de esa
forma la música cautiva nuestra atención
en su momento encargado de la promesa de
un inminente desenlace desde algo que
sabemos que va a ocurrir y sin darnos
cuenta ya lo esperábamos
[Música]
después de eso padre me vio y me abrazó
emocionado yo soy yo estaba
miré y le dije no sé por qué estoy
llorando si no es tristeza lo que siento
ese momento marcó mi vida fue a los 7
años que decidí dedicar mi vida a la
música porque quería recrear ese momento
entenderlo y después compartir y
contagiarlo veamos si podemos lograrlo
aquí y ahora yo creo que es contagioso
cuando les conté esta nota inesperada
de esa llave a nuevas opciones que
finalmente se transforma en la puerta a
este gran triunfo musical lo que hice
fue puntualizar un fenómeno muy simple y
al mismo tiempo muy común en la vida
misma las expectativas si el tercer
mandamiento
efectivamente hubiese terminado así
nuestra percepción de lo ocurrido se
enmarcaría dentro de ciertos parámetros
de expectativas básicamente recibimos lo
que esperamos la música concluye el
público se acomoda 12
los instrumentistas se relajan un
segundo hasta que el director que está
vuelve a levantar las manos en señal de
embestida para arremeter con el último
movimiento
[Música]
ah
funciona la música impacta de todas
formas pero no es lo mismo esa
transición que escribió vettel no sólo
cumple con la función de conectar una
música con otra sino que genera otro
tipo de expectativas
desde esa nota inesperada hasta la
búsqueda de nueva estabilidad en el
ritmo la melodía la armonía y esa
textura que crece y desemboca en algo
mayor pero en el intertanto nuestra
mente reacciona comienza a buscar
alternativas escenarios posibles y
petrov en los sabe por eso esa
disolución y divagar de la música nos
confunde y esa confusión genera
expectativas que son mezcla de
predicción y disposición a seguir siendo
sorprendidos ya que la misma música nos
acaba de demostrar que todo es posible
en un nivel extra musical se parece a mi
propia actitud antes y durante el
concierto la información de mi padre fue
un incentivo para llegar al teatro lleno
de expectativas a reconocer lo que ya
sabía a constatar pero una vez de que me
sorprendió ya todo era posible el poder
evocador de la música proviene en gran
medida de su capacidad de generar
prolongar suspender o incluso traicionar
expectativas pero que esperamos de ella
de la música misma una melodía en el
acompañamiento
una idea que se presenta dialoga
y encuentra un cierre
una nueva idea
más jocosa todo apacible esperable
expectativas cumplidas
jaja
si lo inesperado
drama propiedad
[Música]
no se veía venir
porque es más fácil predecir desde la
consistencia como este producto de paso
estamos diseñados para buscar
estabilidad y asegurarnos una predicción
se gatillan asociaciones y la memoria
saca conclusiones la consistencia nos
permite anticipar
y aceptado y una de las fuentes de
placer al escuchar música es cuando
nuestras expectativas se cumplen pero
cuando perdemos el control de la
predicción cuando no se cumplen
gran recurso del romanticismo
franz liszt juega con este sorprender
una melodía apasionada la arrebatada que
comienza un viaje
e
pero regresa
y ahí cuando todo parecía ir por el
mismo camino seguro predecible
esto se abre una puerta como alternativa
que desestabiliza pero fascina
cuanto más
[Música]
fue cómo encontrar opciones que no se
veían posibles
i
y el desafío a las expectativas no se
use un contraste
mahler sentencia oscuras la vida oscura
es la muerte seré desesperanzada la
música toma un nuevo giro
pero además esta música tiene un dejo de
movimiento de baile de vals y claro el
estilo la tradición y la herencia
también generan expectativas
i
porque mal en ese heredero de toda una
tradición vienesa
donde esta música es parte de su adn
y el de nosotros
y bueno se sonrieron algunos a reconocer
este vals de strauss
que por cierto también está lleno de
pequeños juegos de expectativas como
estos sutiles cambios en el tempo ese
tipo
pero qué tanta ira sera
dos sorpresas más radicales
nuevas
a
como les dije la tradición está el
inconsciente colectivo y a través de
gestos como éste 123 puntos 3 podemos
reconocer incluso un distorsionado y
decadente vals escrito antes de la
primera guerra mundial
a
y
no es como un fantasmagórico eco de ese
vals vienés
ah
esas notas al parecer inconexas son
productos de años de transformación de
reglas musicales richard wagner fue uno
que contribuyó en su caso siendo un gran
manipulador de expectativas
música sugerente llena de lo mismo
donde cada nota cada sonido se aferra el
próximo se arrastra se adhieren
ah
pero que cambia permanentemente de
dirección
[Música]
pero no todo lo que suena puede ser
inesperado
un silencio también puede ser provocador
y dejar preguntas abiertas
[Música]
el ensordecedor silencio
devis y su sensual perú de la siesta de
un fauno y ese sugerente silencio al
comienzo
el silencio elemento esencial de la
música más que ausencia de sonido es un
recurso expresivo fundamental y uno de
mis silencios favoritos es ese silencio
cómplice cargado de expectativas el que
ocurre antes de que la música sea
ah
[Música]
pero también cada nuevo silencio
regalando instantes de elucubración
y
siendo parte del discurso y conectando
ideas que pueden seguir creciendo
ah
con tras mes
estabilidad
e inestabilidad
a propósito la estabilidad del pulso
y como lo agrupamos es una reacción
instintiva que aparece apenas
identificamos regularidad 121 puntos
pero cuando ya ni siquiera podemos
anticipar esta agrupación yo solo nos
tira hasta la merced de lo inestable
[Música]
y escuchar música
muchas veces es como leer una buena
novela policial de esas en las que dudas
hasta el muerto
y donde el nudo argumental y el
inminente de este enlace te sean más
sensibles al cómo disminuye el grosor de
las páginas expectativas en el peso
sobre la punta de tus dedos el estado de
atención cambia es activa y
aceleradamente especulativo ya no es si
esto entonces los otros si no y si esto
luego esto esto o lo otro como todo en
la vida en la naturaleza del arte
también está presente esa idea de que
hay que esperar lo inesperado pero ojo
que lo inesperado no solamente tiene ese
gustito la primera vez por algo volvemos
a leer un clásico a ver una película oa
escuchar una y otra vez la música que
tanto nos gusta en parte porque nos
gusta experimentar me de la seguridad
como un niño que lee el mismo cuento
todas las noches desde la tranquilidad
de saber cómo termina pero además la
relectura a través de la memoria nos
regala otros detalles nos hace poner
atención a otros lugares a escuchar la
melodía sino el acompañamiento por
ejemplo y descubrir que esa hermosa
música había pasado desapercibida aún si
siempre estuvo ahí
reconocer pero también para redescubrir
un juego infinito de expectativas o la
relación entre el intérprete y el oyente
cómo lo va a hacer seguro que distinto
como me lo aprendí en la grabación que
conozco resbala gracia si la música es
un organismo que respira y vive en el
instante mismo en que suena solo ahí la
música es y escucharla en vivo nos
permite vivir ese momento lleno de
expectativas
cuando termina el concierto mi papá me
lleva a conocer al director yo lo vi y
me puse a llorar de nuevo
sin decir nada pensaba tú eres el
responsable de estas lágrimas
él me miró un poco descolocado pregunto
si pasaba algo más que mal muchas pueden
ser las razones del llanto un niño de
siete años mi padre todavía emocionado
le hizo un resumen y al entender el
impacto que la música había tenido en mí
el director me abrazó y me dijo bueno
por esto hacemos lo que hacemos
ese día cambió mi vida mis expectativas
han sido desde entonces cambiar las de
ustedes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]